you and me so anyway all right let's do
this play it straight from the beginning
see what happens I don't know I don't
think I think what they did was they
changed like the ending of it I don't
need to know this we've already seen
this right some of you most see you
probably all of you you're a fan of mine
I hope you've seen it all right anyway
so here I am again the old familiar
places I do got to remember stead look
very pretty
mmm the trees working smell so I'm gonna
take this shortcut down into the way
because I want to get to the new stuff
as far as possible there's the radio
tower that I'm gonna try to find that
brick wall always there probably
probably probably now you guys need to
tell me if I'm gonna miss something that
is important I'm gonna be checking
twitch or chat regularly and if you guys
see something that you need from me to
get then let me know and I'm also gonna
turn down my microphone volume and also
guys remember could get loud I might
scream I might get loud watch your ears
listen smart look either way now we're
back into the house it's been a while
since I played this it's almost been
like how long's it been when did this
first come out it came back in like
March I don't really know it but it's
been a long time
hello there any demonic entities in this
building can't thank you enough good
bone appears to be dead good great
excellent
Gudivada and the flashlight man it has
been a long time bone appears to be dead
good excellent I'm not even gonna try to
get all the memorabilia or maybe I
shouldn't try to get all the member of
okay there's number Q we do remember IRA
washa
I remember you oh damn what I would I
would uh I remember where all the notes
are in here huh
Slenderman are you in here Kyle for your
interview huh
I really don't remember it's been so
long I played through the game only
twice once unnormal and once on hardcore
and the hardcore one was very annoying
I really don't remember
oh my go this is slender the arrival and
there were some changes that were made
or some new ending or something oh
really I remember how much of a deuce
you were oh yeah that one's locked I
gotta find the pages are the key I don't
remember I don't remember no don't I
remember I can I remember what did I
need to find don't remember him there's
a key I think right let's be a key yeah
I can't get round until I find the key
did anyone see the key
oh there we go that's right there's a
page there and there's three pages in
the house don't remember I really
sincerely don't remember anybody know
anybody know anybody know what the hell
I'm supposed to do because I am at a
loss I need the key I figured that where
the hell is the key seriously where the
oh oh no okay thought I thought I saw
didn't see
check the place said okay okay that's a
good idea I remember that thing check
the playset there's nothing on the place
said I'd check that what about that that
playset that's probably the one you
meant right yeah there's a page on that
or remember now there's a book pardon
run that by me again give it out one
more time there we go got it okay number
three we yeah I got an achievement I got
an achievement so now what I do I didn't
get a key I still didn't get what I
needed this door probably still locked
what the hell's the key there's a key I
don't know hi Bob
hi Bob hi hi Bob
okay seriously where the F is the key I
got to be joking me this dumb game I'm
remembering why I hated it cuz it was so
stupid
everything was in the wrong place and it
was so dumb and dumb is what's key
seriously I'm looping now I've been in
the same places over and over again
oh the key is upstairs well good for me
oh wait a minute
die not going there die not going this
roof uh it's in the one room the one
room I don't go the keys in the one room
one room I don't go in really really and
how did I overlook that one I'm gonna
kill ten [ __ ] okay whatever huh wait
it's no one room one room the one room I
didn't go it either way
time to go see what happened to miss
screamy lady over there
hey stop screaming we all got problems
what do you mean the door appears to be
locked you do shall go around screw you
I hear some thought I heard some
some thought I heard some anybody here
that how'd it be here that the one rum
it's rum it's not room what is that over
there oh is this what they changed it's
not level transition it's straight into
it that's awesome maybe maybe I maybe
that's not it maybe I'm maybe I'm
delusional maybe I'm fooling myself what
is that this is different this is new I
haven't seen this before what's this
what are you oh no am I playing the
general oh how delightful well what do
we have here and why is this set up like
this well well well what's going on my
little pretties oh really
hello it's gonna be was this fatal blaze
are upset oka Oakside house wait is that
the house I was just in I don't know
what was that a different house
Slenderman let lit the whole forest on
fire before so I'm sure he won't stop at
a single house oh we know it before is
in the future it hasn't happened yet
he's going to light the whole place up
was that go - what is that hey I see you
can't get away from me what I get I get
what I get
oh well whatever I'll just keep going
wait a minute no no no no no no lice
lice and slander it's pointing me in the
wrong direction it's messing with my
head everyone it's messing with my head
I can't let it get to me hmm
yeah I agree he's a Yuda yes yes I am I
am a youtuber how did you know did you
know that I'm a youtuber trigger to
guitar alrighty then I got to remember
to do the long-distance thing
this is totally new I haven't seen a
lickety-split of any of this where does
that road go hey I'm that good road goes
there but I'm gonna find out what this
go to visit where does that go where
does that go oh it goes to a locked
fence there something over there so
someone nah alright nothing over there I
think I saw the portrait of Charlie
Matheson Charlie Mason
Charlie Magoo be gully hello hi Charles
Matheson jr. five five five three seven
nine nine see ya Sunday the arrival got
an update ergo there's some new stuff
nope uh-uh Oboro no no no yeah but did
you guys hear that you guys knows very
quiet you man guys may not have heard
that but tell me you guys heard that
right
oh man no man what is that okay
nevermind I won't go in there geez where
you gonna be like that okay
this is new Jimmy you'll run that by me
again so one more time say after my face
okay I thought that was something some
things in here oh hi who the hell are
you
you're new or you know we're gonna come
any closer til you tell me who you are
okay go is winning
curiosity wait how do I can I even get
to him/her it okay no clue hi
what's wrong with you what's wrong with
you what's wrong with you
they go that way wrong with you
Oh wanna hi hi
haha knew something was gonna happen
still got me anyway
alright that's good good good good good
good so glad that happened so glad that
happened
right okay how's everyone doing after
the first heart attack of the game good
glad to hear it
where am I going now did this even lead
anywhere I don't think I was even
supposed to go in there oh goodness
gracious
wait is erse how do I get to the second
floor it's our way up there know if
there's a way up there yeah yeah I don't
think there's a way upstairs unless you
guys want to tell me there is come on
alright okay then what's all this then
what's all this some masonry they're
gonna build a house before an epidemic
of fire came oh wait no there was
another generator that's right I'm all
out of Sprint juice these people need to
do some conditioning because they are
out of shape like no joke that one game
where I couldn't run for like three feet
what was that that was a recent one I
played it I can't remember what it was
uh camera mare the name of it was like
in an elementary school in your dream
couldn't run for more than three feet
the big baby what is this this is all
new looking for hello traffic cone you
seem a little out of pace why would a
traffic cone be necessary over here am I
even supposed to go here
okay all right okay that's how you want
to play it
Oh an invisible wall you know and stop
making an invisible wall you could have
just moved the chain-link fence a few
feet made it a bit more believable but
whatever I'm no game designer oh wait no
am i it's either up this way oh there's
a road here okay I got it I got it I got
it everybody within deep sorrows was
that it that might have been it how long
my string no no do I feel like it dawn
dawn oh that's just a wheel I thought
that was a face all right Oakside Park
wasn't this some don't I'm getting like
some flashbacks there was a game a
slender game that had kind of like this
slender's woods that's what it was
slender's woods I remember it kind of
had a thing like this in it maybe it's
just a cabin in the woods and it's
ringing some bells that way but also
because
oh so now we kick up the done on and
then anon aah demonic music is what I
was fencing he came for me why didn't I
listen he was right he said this would
happen
help me need CR he knows how to end this
come find me don't let him in ok oh oh
there we go
well that's a better transition into the
next zone snazzy that's a better
transition into the next zone than it
was before so that's good that's good
good ah here we go now we're into the
page collecting part if it's still a
page collecting part which I imagine
that it is that is at the heart of all
Slender games page collecting some more
advanced version of scrapbooking all
right see personal floatation devices so
that you don't drown from fear Oh which
way do I go okay over here okay
so it begins now we're in the woods now
so I don't know if they change this up
and it has been a while since I played
this but I remember the general layout
of it so there ain't gonna be no
Slenderman just yet it's gonna be just
you me and not missing any really
obvious pages haha really obvious huh
you can give me I know you guys like to
get all my cases are the little things
that you see and I do not
oh the old familiar thumpy thump it's
been a while how are you doing today
good good I'm so glad
alright so generally it's a circular
pattern I'm going to try to follow the
woods or the road some respect and is
there bam got it
number two doing good now is there
actually anything over there no there's
not that was the other potential
entrance to the woods gonna try to make
the center area the last place to go
save my sprint Amanda need it
tweety tweety no that's not slender
playing the drums that slender's
marching band he's got them all in the
background just like in a zombie Oh bang
and then they're gonna start playing a
fanfare as soon as they catch me cuz
it's my birthday
sorry it's somebody's birthday happy
birthday whoever's birthday it is where
Z where Z those ears did you guys wear a
no sale where is it all areas
I didn't sin but now I see him he's
still it he's it coming towards me
I forgot that he slides in this one is
it this one that he slides her is it the
other one which one um which slender
game does he slide there was one game
that he slid and I did not like it just
like yeah hey
how's it going okay alien the toilets
was slender taking a slender dump until
he sat on his slender rump and then he
had himself a slender slump to leave ah
I'm gonna not finish the rest of that
rhyme because I don't many Oh No
then he went outside for a slender jump
and then he and then he ate himself
until he was slender plump and then God
my brains not working right now don't
ignore me
ignore me then he ate a slender Crump
Pitt no that doesn't work at all no I'm
stupid to do okay so I think I miss this
car in the hill I always miss the car in
the hill and then I'm gonna make a left
turn and I should be able to circle
around get everything else that I need I
don't think I've missed anything good
bird it within the respective oh hey hi
there friend how you doing doing good
good that's a family dead great
okay all right I did that thing I did
that thing that you guys hate are you
doing I look behind me I always do it
but I think it actually helps I think it
helps you guys may not think it helps
but I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure I'm
the Slender expert here those are this
really tall grass there's the other
potential entrance into the woods and
here comes my six-page any minute now
I'm gonna see it any second now it's
gonna dare it is I do it had to be here
ha
oh there you're okay Jimmy don't slide
over here yes campfire and then fight
off boom at some porta-potties I got it
I got your numbers Lindy boy I got your
number it's five five five four eight
five four five five five four five four
four five so what was that number again
you guys remember it from a cami I cami
okay there's the building and that means
the porta potti is just over yonder I
could follow the road if I was smart but
I'm not known for my intelligence I'm
not known for my screams didn't you know
I'm known for my devilish good looks
okay this is not good word ah I'm gonna
go take a slender dump in the bird
little geek on a tree in the bird body
bird body for the birds
where's it I got [ __ ] ha ha ha ha yeah
kiss this slender rump are you gonna get
me no matter what I don't care whatever
I I what I didn't care but by 5 5 4 5 8
9 and a 405 84 that's it yeah good job
everybody good job
and nice job this lady for running in
the trees like a [ __ ]
yeah keep running that's gonna help yeah
I did get all a thank you very much I
got all eight dudududud oh hello
I seem to be on my side here we go
ooh this florist how I remember its
leaves glittering from the truth I don't
remember the leaves grinning from the
tea cup but this is so beautiful this
tree okay enough of it where am I now is
this Luers it's the same looks the same
I remember that old shanty isn't that
delightful well wait is wade here too
Wade good bye Wade get out of here with
your stench your stinky stink your
stanky stink that smells stinky well
then this is how you're going to be I
might just have to punch you in the
balls I gave you the old what for back
at the oh the please six yeah I seem to
have missed some
hey look it's Charley Matheson I don't
remember the people why is there another
shot oh because obviously his parents
would have put them up all over the
place was not good for him
great okay how about no you wanna not
shut up
all right good job good job everybody
good work remember when I couldn't find
this door that was a hootenanny that was
a laugh and a half look at candy cane
why is there candy cane here no
seriously why is there a candy cane here
this is the most out of place thing I've
ever seen in the entire game why is
there candy cane here
was there a Christmas special that I
didn't know about okay my favorite part
of this entire game but now that I know
your tricks I'm not gonna have to deal
oh wait why is that fenced off like that
why is that gated hey wait don't summon
over there oh wait no it turns on what
it is yeah it all opens up anybody know
I'm gonna go this way
no I'm gonna go this way all right
so the little douche is gonna come
a-runnin and I'm gonna shine my light in
his face and he's gonna die or at least
that's what I hope happens yeah sure if
that's what's actually gonna happen I
hear you and that's just me or am I
going extra slow right now is it just me
or am I going extra super uber slow shut
up
I am going really really slow guys
really slow why why hi
no no no no no yep uh-huh
I don't like you remember I do not like
you I think you're kind of a douche yep
I hear you no no no why no no then Big E
no no little piggy no go home are you
I hear the pitter-patter of your little
footsies where are you I hear your
pitter pattering oh good there's one
right there that means four right in the
same area that's good right that's good
isn't it that's good is that good I
don't know if that's good I may or may
not be clear I'm just talking to myself
now
maybe the stream died a long time ago
tonight I hear you a little chipper in
bastard piggy no no looper guy I got
your number with I'm okay I stopped I
was like why why why am I not why am I
not moved in always the one down there I
don't know nope nope nope nope nope nope
nope nope nope nope nope go okay so I
got four of them already that's good
there's a little kid chasing me that's
bad baby douche I can shine them with my
flashlight and blind him that's good
he'll still keep coming after a while
that's bad
where that I don't know where the other
generators are that's bad
okay there's one down there I should
have gone down there but I can't jump so
kind of okay you're gonna come at me bro
come at me wait for it wait for her
wait are you that guy he's the guy he's
the guy he's the guy isn't it nut burnt
building he's a burnt guy that's why his
face is all messed up he's not born that
ugly or maybe he was and maybe he looks
better now
I don't know I can't sprint I'm all out
of sprinting juice okay this is war and
more gianna way to go no no no no no no
I say no Oh was that it
oh I thought I saw the glow of anew nope
yeah that's right that's right yeah
who's your dad not me cuz I'm a lady
my character in this game is a lady okay
so I'm gonna blind him once more and
then I'm gonna go look in the side rooms
in here there were more rooms in here
that's right that's right good things
Lennie's not bothering me that's awfully
nice of them no getting closer I don't
like it potential for one in it
yep good good nope there nope nope
aha yes yes I love it I like it I love
it I want support up get out of here
with you bull now don't you do the same
thing you did same thing same same thing
you stayed locked up you
I can't sprint I am so slow why am I
deciding to walk the slowest possible Oh
am I gonna bug through this time did you
fix that one game alright we did it yeah
all right
thank you okay so now Boop
all right oh we're moving right through
this Lehmann ah I almost missed that all
right where are we now
bong Bing Bing bong Bing bong remember
the glitch what the hell is a glitch
what are you talking about well isn't
this just pretty is the Sun going down
I'll love I see you over there how come
why is it that yeah I'm going at a
respectable clip now even when I'm
walking but been there no I couldn't
have been bothered I couldn't be
bothered that anything else over here is
anything new it is wall right there
anything that I should know about
I know there was like the UM the outlook
up there was the place up there and that
is a big area that looks like rust is
that just me or does that look like a
mountain rust Bob does that look like
the mountain in rust I'm gonna assume
you said yeah the mountain that always
bothered us excuse me oh sorry I didn't
know that I was supposed to go to the
left of the tree
all right where was that path up is that
no no no this way it was a way to get up
by the way that's a pitiful zoom on a
camera if you're gonna die with this
camera you could at least spend a little
money on it up there is that the way up
there is that the way up there set the
up way there I think that is yeah see if
there's anything new up here I doubt it
but I'm just gonna assume who edit oh
there's that post with number 10 nope I
see nothing new I see nude I see nothing
yeah that's right this the more I sprint
the slower I walk if that's stupid
you're stupid
not you but the game you're stupid
love the music the music is delightful
the music is just alive
and there's a flare this is something in
there there we go there's my flashlight
good old flashy is this the same it is
the same isn't it kind of maybe yeah
yeah yeah it's the same okay what do we
have here I want to die I want today i
vant today I want to die hands have
teeth
hey des baux okay why am i hearing that
right now can you see it
no hello hi time to play this mode
uh-oh I gotta close this this was like
for some reason this was the UH
this was the freakiest car to this
entire game for me this was just like
absolutely oh I did not like it can that
one's not open who's who's playing the
piano
why would I leave every door open anyway
why would that be a thing that I do hi
it's just a concept of this whole part
is genius for a horror thing it's like
you're alone in the house and something
wants in really badly shut up
now now no
shut up
yeah I've almost got them all what's
that last door oh well he's re in he's
already inside so that was bad
God yeah just the idea that always gets
me I mean that's where it gets me right
hi bunny
alright yeah that whole sequence just
gives me the worst heebie-jeebies ever
it's just it's just made of us look this
potential there but it would be a very
short game if he made it that way if
it's good sequencer to get there wait
wait whoa whoa whoa whoa wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute hey
hey wait a minute
average of that Robbie probably well how
many more happy okay see see candy canes
what's the deal what's the deal with the
candy canes is slender Santa gonna come
find me
slender Santa that was one of my
favorites slender the Christmas special
I love that one I love that one too
kathan I never beat it what did that say
I didn't read it candy cane part two you
like it I love it I want some more of it
Kaiba
time to start the fire huh the fire in
my loins burn aah aah dude look at this
have they been everywhere and I just
haven't seen all of them what's going on
here
whoopee skating OOP eat again boobies
kid so many candy canes wait a minute is
this the same yeah this is the same I
remember the Haws
I remember the ha ha ha I'm sorry I'm
sorry yeah I remember this I remember I
remember all of you
I remember everything in this place what
the hell is going on here
oh good wait there it is Oh what I'm
what okay so I remember how to do this I
did this up with Jillian time it's
practically burned into my skull oh that
is rather delightful hi I hear you can
you not wait oh oh oh I got away I
thought that was gonna be the death of
me
No get off of me Galla me no no I refuse
really I remember I hate this part I
hate it a lot I hate it so much that I
want to kill myself I hate that part
with a fiery burning passion it is the
worst part in any game I've ever seen in
my life it is just this this part is the
worst the game makers should be ashamed
this is all I hate this part I hate it I
hate it so much
oh I hope it dies in a fiery hell from
whence it was spawned
oh no no no no no no no no no I don't
think so
I don't think so mr. Slaney man I don't
so I remember the certain trees that
fall down yep that one I can go around
no that is bad
oh we will all right
oh no no no no no no no no I hate this
part so much I hate it I hate it I hate
it I hate it with a fiery burning
passion I hate it it is the worst it is
the definitively it is definitively the
worst ah it is the worst I hate is so
much it is the worst part in any game
ever made I don't know how this is in
any way good I said all these things the
last time I played this game guys it's
not new this is nothing new can I slip
by here I can okay good I
nope okay cuz it used to be when the
ball really right in front of me right
in front of me good good great I'm glad
that oh no no no no no oh what suddenly
I have infinite sprint now I'm happy but
why now
okay so I'm gonna make it am I actually
gonna make it this time
yeah I did it yeah good for me I did it
good job everybody was a team effort I
did man boom [ __ ] got you in your face
now store needs a key I'm gonna fight
Birds it dad a key now is a key now is
there anything else in this place
adding a good sound oh no no no no no no
no what is that what is it what is that
what is it
hello this is new is this old I don't
know something I dare ya I told you
something was in there something spying
me in front of me around me I don't know
can barely see I can't see actually that
and now we meet hard good hi little
friend
I'm say
she
okay wait that's not the end whoa hey
buddy okay madam hahaha holy crap oh hi
hi who are you uh are you doing okay hi
gonna be like that huh gonna be a dick
laughs okay all right okay all right
pretty oh good good I got a note that's
just what I wanted to get when I'm down
here trapped with a monster okay look oh
it's by the stairs get high oh why you
do that oh I see what I see what I need
to do it you do
it's my mama okay
whoa
all right wanna am i back in the burn
house I find the second floor of the
burn house I am our night I am I'm right
aren't I I'm right am i right I may not
be no I'm in the first floor the burn
house okay I know how to get to you cuz
I got there before there apparently
isn't a front door anymore oh I didn't
know this was here
maybe it wasn't oh hi hi huh
oh it's like The Blair Witch Project
they get dragged off into out of frame
right yep there I go those very Blair
Witch Project II yay good sink hey I did
it
good job that's good I liked it it was
quite a bit of new stuff they're not ton
of stuff but still not bad I liked it a
lot that's a big development team not
bad but either way that was it was
really cool I was good ah
all right so that's the end of that sir
if I blew anyone's eardrums out
Oh anyway that was it very special
Thanks
all right okay everybody enjoy that you
like that you like that you like that
good good good good okay all right
so that's that see there any extras got
booked nah there's nothing I've seen
everything so there you have it
everybody
slender the arrival and I think that
will just about do it for this live
stream it's been two hours two hours not
a very long live stream but still not
bad at all it was still pretty fun
anyway so I am going to do stuff I am
very busy I have to go get some food I
haven't eaten at all today I have not
eaten from the time I woke up to the
time now so it has been about 12 hours
since I hate so I'm gonna go get some
food to eat because I am dying of hunger
and I am going to do something else
maybe record some videos I'm kind of
tired but maybe maybe I'll get something
done but either way so thank you guys so
much for joining me thank you for much
for being here I don't do these
livestream very often I used to do them
a lot more than I did now but maybe I'll
pick it up again but so here's sincerely
from me to you guys thank you guys so
much for being here and for being here
with me and and I need to get ah I was
wearing a hat yes I was wearing right
oh now my hair looked weird I'm gonna
put it back on what do you weigh so yeah
thank you guys so much for being here
for me um thank you for doing everything
to support the channel odd keep it up
since I have you here I don't know um
have you guys watched the newest
animations yeah I hope you did um if
it's too much to ask um be sure to leave
a like on that video I don't usually ask
but since you're all here it I don't
know if it even helps anymore I don't
know I really don't know if it helps
some people say that likes don't even
matter anymore but if it doesn't matter
then please help spread the word about
the channel as usual I know you guys do
it everyday but just go out of your way
if anything share either the compilation
markiplier highlights or that animation
is perfectly fine just take a moment
take a few seconds share with a friend
whether it be on face
Twitter pull up a chair and tell some
about that tell someone about the
channel and help spread the word keep it
growing SuperDuper fast so just thank
you guys so much you know thank you for
being here I want I want to do this more
just like off-the-cuff live streams I
should have it more planned out
beforehand I had hope to spend a bit
more time on rust before we killed
everything but apparently we did so
sincerely from the bottom of my heart to
you guys thank you so much for
everything that you've done
I'll there will be more videos tomorrow
I know I only had the animation today
but I was hoping the live stream would
make up for it but either way thank you
all so much for watching
no annotations cuz it's a live stream
you all have a wonderful day keep being
the awesome people that you are so thank
you again everybody and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye bye I
have to say bye for about ten hours
because I got to make sure that the
stream doesn't cut out before then bye
goodbye bye
I
by